- Well, one of Alix's
Get Ready With Me posts
that went viral, oh, this is amazing,
was her getting ready for
a Miami Dolphins game,
so let's see that; I love this.
- [Alix] I have this tiny
little Jimmy Choo bag
which I think goes with the heels.
Feel like a mom picking
up her kids from school.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
(audience claps)
I'm like, "Okay,
I love that you think a mom
could look, like,
that together.
- Listen.
- picking up, I know, it
is amazing, but so the mom,
the moms came,
they came out, right?
- The moms humbled me
very quickly.
(everyone laughs)
They were like, "Girl."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- This is on the way
to school.
This is them on the, (laughs)
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
okay, so this is me after,
- Woo.
- Yes, yeah.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
(audience claps)
This is me; this is after sleeping
with your children, and they kick you
- Wow.
- all night,
and it's super fun.
No, my goal is to look like you
in that video at some point.